[Musique]
et oui il y a une fuite annonçant dans
les médias que je
souffrais d'un cancer du poumon c'est
vrai j'ai été j'ai appris cette maladie
au mois de mai dernier j'ai subi une
première opération début juillet un
traitement qui continue depuis quelques
semaines j'attendais un petit peu pour
en parler
[Musique]
et si j'en parle d'abord je pense qu'il
faut pas avoir peur du cancer j'en ai
déjà eu un la prostate vous le savez
j'en ai parlé pour essayer de
d'améliorer la prévention même chose
pour le poumon j'ai cru que ça ne
pouvait arriver qu'aux autres pendant
des années et des années on m'a dit
d'arrêter de fumer j'y ai pas cru
j'aurais dû arrêter